عام ثقيل على النظام الايراني
تظاهرات تجتاح كل المدن وتخنق قلب النظام
لكن عام 2023 قد يكون اسوا على النظام قد
يسقطه وفق تقرير للالكونه
السلطات على مناقشه اصلاحات داخل نظام
الحكم من اجل محاولات تهدئه الاحتجاجات
ومن هنا ظهرت نداءات من قبل المتشددين
الذين يريدون تعديلات محدوده والاصلاحين
الذين يريدون تغييرات هيكليه
المتشددون يرون ان الاصلاحات المحدوده
باتت ضروره لبقاء النظام ومنع الصراع
الداخليه المتنامي منهم رئيس البرلمان
السابق علي للرجاني ورئيس البرلمان الحالي
محمد باقر قالباف والمستشار الاقتصادي
للرئيس محسن رضائي وام مجلس الاعلى للامن
القومي علي شمخاني هذه الجبهه شددت على
ضروره ان يتخلل نظام عن فرض الحجاب
الالزامي وان الاصلاحات يجب ان تحدث في
نظام الحكم بالبلاد اما الاصلاحيون الذين
همشوا بشكل كبير من قبل مؤسسات النظام في
العامين الماضيين فقد حاولوا تفكير
بوجودهم على المسرح السياسي عبر طرح
اصلاحات بشكل اكبر الرئيس السابق محمد
خاتمي منهم وهو الذي حث المرشد على مدار
الاشهر الماضيه على الانصياع للاصلاحات
الهيكليه وايضا فاطمه رفس جاني ابنه
الرئيس الايرانيه الاسبق هاشمي رفسا جوني
والتي التقطت مجتبى خام ايه نجل المرشد
واكدت له ضروره اجراء الاصلاحات
بين امل الاصلاحين وتفضيل المتشددين
تستقبل ايران اعامها الجديد وسط تقديرات
تعكس معظمها وضع الاقتصاديا مؤلما